كانت اسكتلندا على موعد مع اولى مشاركاتها
في كاس العالم في النسخه التي اقيمت في
سويسرا عام
1954 رغم ان هذه المشاركه كانت كماثيلتها
السبعه اللاحقات من ناحيه خروج
الاسكتلنديين من دوري المجموعات الا انها
جلبت العار لهم
ارسل الاتحاد الاسكتلندي لاعبيه الى
سويسرا التي وصلت فيها درجات الحراره الى
40 درجه مئويه بزي اكمام قمصان طويله
مصنوعه من الصوف الخشب خسرت اسكتلندا ذات
الاكمام الصوفيه في مباراتها الاولى مع
النمس بهدف دون مقابل فيما سحقتها
اوروغواي بسبعه اهداف نظيفه وعند سؤاله عن
السبب في الخساره المذله امام اوروجواي
قال مدافع اسكتلندا
اسكتلندي
سويسرا دوما بسبب وجود الجبال فيها وظن ان
لاعبيهم سيسافرون الى القاره القطبيه
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]